[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
and if you wish to speak make sure
please you you tune your microphone on
thinking
okay
good morning everybody and thank you
very much for attending this multi-court
multi-use indoor court facility
[Music]
on the 23rd of july 2020
and we'll start firstly with apologies
please
apologize
so after last month's meeting um
where you had that indicative landscape
plan warren and amani have translated
that into the model because you might
remember
a few months ago seeing the walkthrough
model so it gives a lot more sense of
perspective
of sizes and how it's actually going to
look now
there's still a bit of refinement to do
so we had a meeting with arapata
um last last friday um and spent a
couple of hours with him
at warren amani's office which was very
helpful and we sort of walked him
through this whole thing so he has now
gone away
and is creating a story
a story about the centre from a cultural
perspective and then he's going to
engage
an artist to work with tori and us on
refining the landscape so
some of the landscape plans that you'll
see in ritual talk that we two seconds
um they're indicative shapes so the
detailed design won't be done till we've
actually worked with arapata and the
um and the artist but he's he's doing a
story and it's the same sort of process
he used with he did rotanna for library
he wrote a story about
the significance of the building and
then we got an artist to start to sort
of how that he could um
so he thinks that at the moment as we
only met last friday he's pretty tied up
for the next two weeks but
he's hopeful we'll have everything sort
of finalized in terms of
um ready for approvals by about late
september somewhere
that's the sort of the deadline we're
working to so that's just about that
sort of the context for while we've
we've done this but it does make it much
more useful and then when we get an
artist on board
he or she can then work through the same
sort of process victoria and then you
can actually
because one of my kindly put it all on
the model you can actually alter the
model to reflect the shapes and
everything else
so richard okay great thanks
thanks greg so um yes it was relatively
straightforward of us
to produce the
landscape drawings that tori tabled last
meeting
into the 3d model and i think this makes
more sense now that you've been out
there yesterday and walked over the job
you get a sense of what's there and what
isn't
um all the big main parts are there now
as you know
apart from the canopy frame itself which
will be one of the last things they put
up when they clear the site
this overall image shows a sense
of that cold stream room road
and the slip lane bus drop off one way
that you see in the immediate foreground
um connecting through to the
the car park extension that we talked
about last time across to the hockey
field
the blue hockey field on the right is um
i think we must have just plonked that
in to show
that it would fit that's obviously not
there in the immediate future
it's the second hockey ground so that
would just be green field with the swale
or those bridges that you see at the
moment
so the landscape treatment series of
trees along cold stream road
trees in the car park as you see and
then the main event being the um
the way the sort of outdoor room
treatment is underneath that canopy
structure
but it's just before we leave this one
craig we've started to give thought to
the um location of this main
building sign which is that big black
guy on the left which i think is
at the moment a bit tall but he'll
probably be about half that height
but starting to get a sense of where
that would go
so if we can go through these craig um
looking from the other way
that sort of 2001 monolith will not be
how it is but we just sort of started
giving thought to it
so the the landscape of the car park a
series of
trees and um and green areas that
divide up the car park and that all
drains to that swale on the left that
you see
just for a second yesterday we were
parked about here
um
et cetera
which we'll get to an attack yeah
so you get a sense that there's those
two major car parks the tennis
club will be on the left eventually and
then the um
the various football fields and so on um
organized around the building at the
moment just looks like a
aircraft carrier and a paddock but the
sense of that will come over the next
few years
okay what next so looking across at the
entry as craig just mentioned you've got
the main entry
um in the center there with the yellow
which takes us through to the main
reception and then through into the
sports hall
and the sort of secondary entry on the
left a similar version which gets us to
the sports
sports house and the um and the shared
spaces on the left of that
so two paired entries and there'll be
some signage um
that will organize um on those walls
shortly
and i think the next couple of slides
gets us a bit closer
so so there's cold stream road gym on
the left
main open space on the right and the um
the aerobic studio straight ahead
i think we go to the left now crag down
the building here so you get a sense of
the arrival
next one and where's i think the next
three just walk us along the side of
that building so there's a there's a
colonnade
shelter to walk under the main entry
there um
we're just working with tori and with
arapata about what will happen just on
the left of that entry this would be a
seat and a planter
and the building signage on that wall to
tell you that you've got to weave
where you've set out to get to and then
the gym is on the right
i think the next one's the secondary
entry to the sports house on the left
i think that's all we need to say about
that yep so it's a similar version of
itself and there may well be a directory
talking about who you come to see the
gym on the corner with
its um sliding shutters so that you can
get a sense of looking out to the view
but not necessarily looking in
and i think the next sequence will take
us around the courtyard yeah so the
outdoor frame
some seats along the front which are
very indicative at the moment they will
have a bit of a shape to them
i think that tourists talked to last
time but more of a form
you might recall that there was talk
that the trust will be organizing
a temporary sprint training um
rolled out piece of astro turf uh in the
immediate foreground outside those doors
on the left
and i think craig what that goes out the
first two bays pretty much it comes out
it stops about there so it's contained
so um yeah you get a sense of the
um the canopy which is set up to um
cope with pv panels in the future if
these um do eventually
um next one craig i think we sort of end
up getting down perhaps the next one
again get down to street level
yeah so that's a good one so looking in
from the side
you get a sense of the of the grid
structure of the ground
plane so a series of exposed aggregate
panels in each bay with ash felt around
the perimeter and then
a sequence of grass which is a light
green
and more shaped planting which is a dark
green and then these timber
seating islands and performance islands
which is set up in the center there
and there's a flush piece of timber in
the middle and
i um i think we imagine craig that this
is
this is how it's going to be but the
detail will be refined
um
trees
so the sense of it's very similar to the
canopy outside the library where the
seating and the sort of undercroft of
trees and shade and so on
in the immediate foreground that little
timbery thing just indicating these
um bridge walk overs the swales so
there's a direct line
in the center there and then off to the
right to get across that swale
which will be dry most of the time but
obviously this time there might not be
um yeah so you get a sense of that it's
quite a big space but divided into these
sort of room-like spaces and i think
creating the next slot just
take us through
so you see these timber islands just
sort of float there with the plumbers in
the middle i think they look pretty cool
i think the next one gets us down into
the
that's the next one what you might
experience
so you see those islands up to about 500
off the ground which is a sort of seat
bench height
and you get a sense of the height of the
planting and the grass and so on
so sorry to interrupt richard and craig
so
it's a vehicle access still for moving
and out so that's all
good
but basically there's still room there
to get
trucks in for loading gear and food
trucks
i think the next lot just give us
further views of this yeah
so those the exact size and positioning
of those guys in the foreground which
are
sort of a concrete base with a timber
top
they have yet to be fully worked through
but that's that you get a sense of how
they'll be
i think the next lot just take us
through yeah get underneath and you get
a sense of that
sure just a quick question with those
grids
up there those loot light louvers have
that been tested
for windage or noise if it's really
really windy
does that have any effect um i'm not
sure but does it have any effect if it's
really really windy
um we have worked through with the
supplier that very question
so it's in there in the mix i mean we
haven't done
you know simulated testing or anything
like that
but the question has been asked earlier
in the contract
part of that sorry part of the design of
this includes
so the engineers actually will give us a
certificate at the end of ps1
on robustus and wind as well because
that's obviously been a factor in terms
of our longest scales
and that will be quite exposed to it
there could be
there could be some noise for it but our
best advice at the moment is without
doing the modeling which would cost us
thousands because i'd actually have to
replicate this and
do a whole model we've got a quote with
a three and a half thousand or something
and even then they said that wouldn't be
and that would be indicative only
and they need to get a whole laboratory
type set up which
we didn't even get a price for um but i
don't think it should be too much of an
issue we're very careful about the
robustness and also the height of it
and with the amount of sound proofing
around the courts i don't think any
noise is going to transfer it in
the kai poi one um you do get some noise
and kaiapoi roof which
we're working with because the guys know
but that's actually nothing to do with
the canopy
that's actually a grill around the heat
plump upstairs which we're looking to
resolve at the moment but
this is very robust
i just happen to know that greg had
livers
and his property at fernside and they
took them out because
they got it got really noisy and um so
i just would just ask these are quite
rope you can't
tell from this sketch but
these are actually quite big and quite
robust and they don't adjust
so the adjustable ones actually are more
prone to lawyers because they're all
flexible
these are actually rigid so there is no
angle
where you've got the mouse that they
don't that angle won't change
um very similar to the the ones we've
got around outside
ring gear library um and they've been
there for 20
whatever years now um built 96
and we've never had any trouble with
those but i think the flexible ones do
have
and i certainly know other people's
similar experiences
yeah and they're not light enough to
drum in the wind like those smaller ones
are i mean the kuiper ones are very
similar
okay i think there's only a couple more
craig yeah so they're just various views
of the same thing that gives a sense of
that
the others give us a look from the
inside
that's quite good actually seeing what
you'll see when you're there so that's
the last one that just looking out from
the sports hall to the north
so you get a sense that it'll be fine
with with large groups of people but
also with small groups you know just
during the week
i think that's us great
just one thing i'd like to ask place
cars you've got in the car park i don't
see a yellow beat up
the architect's jalopy is not there
either you're right
yes can we go back to the front where
it's got the
the panels those panels are at the front
of the sports channel
asked a wee while ago yeah about timber
or aluminium yes so what have we
resolved on that
it was aluminium it was yeah thank you
this now what we'll do is um we'll use
this presentation here to work with the
trust staff to get their feedback and
then we'll refine it with arapata
and see where we get to on on what we
actually do
so when i wanted these images because
it's actually much easier to talk to the
images and the plan will have the plan
as well
but now we've got those we'll arrange a
meeting with rosie and michael et
citroen um
work through that and we'll have tori
then she's got all the detailed
measurements of how big all the gaps are
because that's what the
trust staff need to know really but just
one other thing that
yesterday
when you go inside as well
there any other questions from richard
well done richard thank you very much
yes
big tick right we'll move on now for the
approval of the minutes of the previous
meetings
so if someone
some would like to move that these
minutes are a true and correct record
please thank you mr palmer
second to place thank you
councillor council award
thank you all those a favor please say i
against carrick thank you
now any matters arising from the minutes
please
nothing right we'll move on then
um we'll go to
the project manager's report please
thanks as mentioned just a couple months
ago we've met with arapata so we're
following
that through we've also had a um
a first discussion with the
key trust staff on naming sponsorship
policy because under our heads of
agreement which doesn't affect the
architects and
engineers here et cetera but under their
heads of agreement with the trust
the council has an obligation to produce
a naming and
sponsorship naming rights policy
or agreement and i've done a first draft
that we've met with the
and it was really helpful discussion
because we went through everything that
needed to be covered and
i've still got a bit of refinement to
due to that just so the point so we all
we all got agreement around the table
what needed to be in there there was no
disagreement it was just
some more things i need to put in that i
hadn't thought of before which is why we
had that preliminary discussion
so i'll refine that um and then i'll
circulate that to
the christmas search and what we'll do
probably the next meeting of this group
i thought at the end of it if the
council is
near said you could stay behind then we
could do a briefing with that before it
goes up to council
because it's important that we get some
ownership but it really only affects the
you know the councillors and and um
mayor and christopher so we'll work that
through
and then get it up to council but so far
that's progressing
quite well um the only other
couple of things we're still working
through
on on detail of finishes inside i mean
while it's all specified when you go to
order things there's always some
interesting developments one of them has
occurred is that the
indoor courts itself because of fire
regulations have to have a special fire
retardant coating on the
on the ply that's being used now
when we specified that that was quite
doable and
wasn't a problem but it's turned out
that the the
application of that coding has changed
and how you used to be able to apply it
you can't now
it won't be guaranteed or won't be
warranted so we're just looking
at alternatives because originally
um we used it at kaipoi actually as well
we used a
fireproof product called dekatek which
one romani specified and we've already
got dekatek in some of the ceilings
it would be more robust around the gym
but
it is dearer but now we're doing an
exercise to see with
how much deer it actually is because
we're concerned of the way this coating
has to be applied what maintenance
regime would that would bring
so it may be more cost effective to
spend a bit more
and not have the maintenance because the
maintenance on the decotec is just
washing it really
so we're doing some work on that now and
we'll bring something back to next
next meeting it's certainly worth
exploring um
but that's about the last thing i think
that's sort of left everything else has
been ordered and confirmed but it was
just working with
um dulux dulux actually took over he
used to be a resin product and dulux
have bought that and
changed the recipe
no but so we're working through that but
if we could get
a better product then we'll certainly
bring something back to consider for
next
next meeting we've made a few
minor um changes to ceiling finishes
like we've removed some ceilings in the
store
we've needed very minor but and
changed around a couple of ceiling
finishes in the admin area so
that'll come back at next month's
meeting as well with the cost saving but
we're probably looking in the vicinity
of about you know 25 000 somewhere like
that
um and but that's about it like you
don't expect each month we'll be coming
up with because we've we've been right
through and i mean this is it's actually
been helpful
lockdown was helpful but it did enable a
lot of this detail to get work through a
bit earlier than otherwise we would have
been able to so everything is
now confirmed really so i think that's
basically the end of any
savings and the deca tech you know bull
pending is about the last thing left to
to order blinds are ordered everything
else is ordered and designed so we
um we're pretty well through which
should help us
hopefully in terms of delivery because
leaves are
trying their best to get orders out in
advance and get stuff on site
um so we don't get delivery delays but
no one can
guarantee that at the moment but they're
certainly working as hard as they can to
try and get
stuff through um the only other thing is
we've
um submitted the building consent um
amendment for the
design of the juice bar reception area
there was just some minor
amendments we had to do to that we
withdrew it from the contract at the
time or just left a provisional summon
um because there's still some issues
about accessibility anyway that's all
been
resolved and some of those issues were
how the building actually operates
and how many people would actually be
queuing at the desk to get count to get
tickets and things so we've worked
through that and
it's basically more or less unchanged
and that's
been submitted to the council and has
been um
and we've had an oral indication from
the building unit that it's
all okay we have anything right and yet
but we'll get that
um and otherwise i think all is going
pretty well happy to answer any
questions that
anyone's got anyone
questions thank you the the
material that you just were talking
about any indication of difference in
cost at this point
no because we've got to do two cost
comparisons dan
um i'd love to have a difference but um
we've got to get the cost of what it
would cost to actually put the existing
material
because now they're saying to get the
finish it has to be
um applied offsite and controlled
conditions and then
erected so that's going to cost more
than was originally planned so we need
to find out what that's going to cost
and then what the new one will cost
because the new one comes re
pre-treated and you just put it up as
sheets so
we'll we'll work that through but you
know we won't have made any just like
it'll come back to you for decision
making next
next month it won't be a you know
nothing will have happened in that time
except we'll have done some more
exploring
well just to clarify so dan
the material is at the high level in the
sports hall and it's the panels where
the acoustic panels are not
and those with long memories might
remember that we
are there for a cost-saving reason
ironically enough
so because early on we had the same
acoustic panel going right through
continuous treatment and we reduced the
quantity of that and added back this
painted plier to save the money
now it's turning into a thing that needs
interrogating but
in terms of what craig's talk to the
area of it is not very big
every other panel or whatever and it's a
long way and one of the cost comparisons
we'll do is whether we just go back to
the original plan a
of the acoustic panels so you know
you'll come back i'll come back next
month with a proper
report with those costs but it's worth
spending time on to
see what we can do because the acoustic
panels could well be the cheapest option
any other questions just
i'd just like to say thank you very much
craig for that report it's very good and
i really appreciate
the work that you've put in and and
these getting everything ordered and
well in advance and just looking at that
pile there of
building material that's ready to go out
but it's just so easy
for site and having everything prepared
beforehand so thank you very much
second up do you wish to speak thank you
okay thank you financial report number
eight
up to the 16th of july
yep before you start sorry i should have
said one other thing
sorry it's my fault my fault but just
introducing the financial report which
ross is more than capable of doing
obviously exceeds his report but
we have started some work with the
consultants in the design on the
the additional car park um which is
adjoining the hockey car park
but that's not part of this 20 8 million
dollar project there's a separate budget
the council voted for that of
a million dollars so in in future
reports
um as we start to expand that money
we'll do that as a separate add-on at
the end so we're not gonna we're not
gonna merge the two so we'll keep this
with the lee's contract
um and when we do the additional west
car park um
it'll probably be a variation to lee's
contract but we'll we'll keep that
separate and i've already talked with
lee's and they're happy to invoice that
separately so we can keep it
simple thanks ross sorry
okay executive summary uh construction
budget of course is the
24.866 million uh progress payments
payment claims one to ten
have been certified um a total of 8.673
amount to date under construction
contingency
we now have type b instructions
estimated cost of
379 thousands and approved at 83
so a forecast contingency expenditure of
000. this forecast exponentially
represents approximately 36 of the
construction
contingency budget of the 1.271
and interesting to note that we've
actually paid 36
of the contract price in the progress
claims so it's quite easy
it also includes the covert claim which
is good
um so the forecast contingency
expenditure has decreased by circa 26
000 this month
uh the most significant changes are the
architectural tender to construction
changes we were able to negotiate that
down to by 49 000 and the reduced site
strip cost came down by 7000 which was
great
the soak pit final cost um cost eleven
thousand dollars more
uh there was a change to the slot drain
type which saved
six thousand dollars um and there was a
change to some petition
head connection details which cost
seventeen thousand dollars
and hollow rats and mice adding up to
eight is the balance
so a total saving of 26 in the month
which is great and hopefully we do that
again next month
as you say craig
um over the page at a risk
um the impact of covert 19 outbreak on
material procurement and program that
says that that's reduced considerably
and the cost of the additional
landscaping as craig is just mentioned
there's no easy risk it's just outside
it's a separate contract
the actual cash flow still appears to be
falling behind
and we still need to get a revised
program from the contractor
yeah otherwise
the rest is detailed thank you
yeah any questions please yes
sorry for my ignorance but type b uh
instructions
is refers
so it's the ones that are on the back
yeah so they're all
type b until we actually approve your
reaction to the project manager
to say it's a craig you might have
covered this at the last meeting the
covert
costs how much is that additional costs
119 000 and
we did talk about last minute it's fine
but um no no
no i know but i mean it's what we said
last month was
we were quite pleased with the
transparency of leads in terms of they
itemized all of the costs that are on a
spreadsheet that they could have charged
us
which was roughly from memory about 176
and then they discounted um
plant they owned they didn't charge for
they took the profit out of it so they
were charging his profit
they also showed the government wage
subsidy um and that brought it down to
000 and then ross and his team worked
through that um
quite a detail and everyone agreed in
the end it was a fair and reasonable
so jim signed that off as part of the
last claim it's actually been
actually cash has been paid to now that
last claim
so just a quick question ross um the
cash flow forecast so
our assumption would be that they would
maintain that that green curve
don't reset at the red line so that
would take us beyond
completion
they leaves we've asked them and they're
working through
they actually are working on it at the
moment but what they're trying to do is
also work out when their supplies will
actually come so while they're ordering
so that cash flow forecast is actually
going to work in there because we've
asked them to fast track
watering so they're trying to work out
when supply is expected
and then they're going to modify so that
that green line there is the original
one we had at the start of the contract
from them um and it hasn't been modified
so richard's right has got to extend out
another month anyway
but it may not go in such a a curve like
that
it could have some bumps in it along the
way depending on on
as materials arrive so jonathan ives
who's a quantity survivors is working on
the moment but
last time i talked to him which is about
ten days ago
and he's not talking about he he was
still waiting then to get sort of
confirmed when we like to actually pay
for some of these things that have come
particularly things like
the flooring and that have significant
cash flow implications
a question for me sort of just almost
picking up on what craig was mentioning
and the
covert response and while you referred
didn't identify
identify or flag any key concerns in
your report craig about that the last
time we met we talked about
the floor coming from the states and i
think there was componentry
out of italy to was it for
um yeah
yeah it's a flooring that wooden floor
or
the sports hall the quartz
and those floor tiles and there's um
the mechanical plant in the mechanical
plant is europe
yeah just i take it we have no update
from our previous advices to our covert
impact on
delivery at this time that's what
they're working on
yeah no i've had no response yet in
terms of no acknowledgement that
anything's in shipment
so sort of just take orders a bit placed
but i've got no
i've got no knowledge that there's any
anything in shipment at the moment
it's a mechanical plant artificially did
you say
you're not going to have the same issues
it's out of it's out of europe
because basically there's no mechanical
plant made in new zealand effectively
um so it all leaves from europe
somewhere and china's involved
not worried about that necessarily but
we're not just just making sure we don't
have the same issues we had with rengar
town hall
with a mechanical plant and then being
able to get it serviced
i think that the i don't the short
answers
hopefully no the the difficulty we have
with rangor town hall originally was
that
to specify a plant that fitted within
that cavity
because that is now six eight years ago
whenever it was um
and plant design keeps changing but at
the time there was only one supplier who
actually made plant that would fit
within the available space
here we've designed the space to fit the
equipment so pal fennec did the design
first
and we actually have plenty of well
plenty room
exaggeration on the on the mets and on
the roof where it's going
if if in the future because you know
we're looking at a 50-year life span
their plant won't last 50 years but
when there is a need for replacement
there's flexibility in terms of the
spacing
so we haven't designed anything that's
built into a tight corner so it is
potentially
okay to any any replacement when needed
i'm into question but it's just that
it's cost us a lot of money to remedy
this
so parts and sourcing if needed
it's all can be obtained here
so it's fabricated and manufactured in
europe but actually the service and
maintenance and
spares come out
correct
when i talk to reese about it it's in
layman's terms
he talked about is more of a toyota type
plant rather than a mercedes in terms of
his readily serviceable common parts and
it's not that
nothing uncommon with it
just regarding back to the wooden floors
and top floor tiles
you haven't heard anything back from usa
they've all confirmed i mean lee's have
confirmed all the orders
and there's been no indication there's
no supply um
but we haven't got um as far as andy and
i know we haven't got
they haven't got any dates yet confirmed
of when delivery is expected and they're
waiting on that but
i don't think they've got anything yet
but they're trying now but
jonathan is chasing it up um chasing all
them up because they're very mindful of
at the moment they've built in a
considerable lead time because they've
asked for stuff to be on site a lot
earlier than it's actually needed
but we don't know if that's going to be
met or not yet so
as soon as we do we'll let you know
thank you just the way things are going
over there
it's a big question mark right
so now if there's no more questions
someone like to move this um
financial report please okay
maybe we accept it thank you
will i speak please say aye okay thank
you
general business please anyone help me
general business so much discuss
i've just got a simple question please
um
i know it would be something that yeah
well no well we'll see well that's
always my response when clients ask me
uh the exit door out of the store you
know past the store room so the main
corridor will exit so that's an
emergency
exit which in theory will exit into the
compound
or not or to the outside to come down
okay so this okay right that was that
was i
thought about that this morning i
thought hold on we can get into the
compound but then they're locked in the
compound
they'll be in that exit door you know
the only people likely to use it are
people who are in the store room or in
the plant room
because if you're in the indoor courts
you're going to come out the indoor
court ones it could be that end changing
room they
may use it if people are in there but it
won't be a big number because the
indoor court people as it were people
are actually on the courts will go out
other exit doors
just just to say thank you craig for
organizing yesterday um
it was excellent being able to go and
have a look through and uh
compliments the contractor and they
probably hit
we're told they had a good tidy up
before we went through but it is
um it's an impressive um building so to
our architects
until um all that are involved in it um
thanks for
it's going to be amazing for our
community um
been a lot of interest as all of us to
drive along i've been looking at it so
it's nice to actually be able to go
through so
well done it's going to be a fantastic
year thank you
thanks dan and we will arrange another
one i mean i think probably the next
site visit will be quite cool when it's
enclosed
because when the rest of the roof's on
and framing up
you know that when you see the indoor
court actually enclosed
and you get a much clearer idea of the
actual spaces because it will be defined
so we'll arrange and
it will also be easier because we'll be
into the summer period where it's
daylight
so we can potentially do it at you know
435 or whatever it's it's it's easier
for leads i mean they've been
carl has been very accommodating he
didn't hesitate when i asked but i mean
they did actually have to stop working
and keep people sight so i'd like to
minimize that but
it will be as i said when there's
natural daylight it'll be quite easy to
get on site you know five or something
like that and
so we'll keep that i certainly think we
want to get another one
another opportunity before um certainly
before christmas and i hope
hopefully somewhere around november
october november somewhere
so the the um the flooring
is being laid today for the the concrete
special special concrete fabulous
big area
it will they're still they're basically
on track
but the timing has changed but because
of weather because when it's too that
the polished concrete you have to get a
higher degree of finish with that than
you do with the rest so they've been
very mindful of working through what's
the
high finish areas and what the weather's
like for that um
so they've restaged the original plan
for how they laid
late flooring but they're you know
basically on track at the moment
and there's been
the weather has affected the concrete
but in terms of the staging of timing
but
they've basically managed to carry on
working mostly which has been really
good so
can i just just say you know i thought
the concrete work finish yesterday
looked really
really good quality and it was quite
encouraging
to see slabs that large laid
that at the moment didn't have much
deformation in them or cracking or
whatever which
possibly will come but um it as it
continues to cure but it's
really really well done so
that will be an asset hopefully we don't
get a decent shake which
would put some lines through it like
like you see through many other
concrete slabs across canterbury
just just on the expected opening is
there any
as far as anyone knows yes i mean it
it's it's a year away effectively still
so
they've it was their estimate
a month later so they're they're saying
at the moment they agree completion date
now is the 21st of june
next year was may 19th or 17th or
something
so it's basically a month later and then
we're estimating that the trust needs to
get in and fit out so that's why we're
sort of talking about a july opening but
as we get
you know closer we'll be able to refine
that a bit more but i think
in terms of any community messaging um
it's probably safer to be saying no late
july
opening
richard just the last question please
with your um update
is that a vote will that be available on
um
for people to look at yes
yes
yeah i would not want to do it no i'd
quite like to i've had a talk with
alistair about that
we'll certainly use them to work through
the trust there's quite a lot of
refinement to happen yet
because particularly those seats they're
there as blobs at the moment
and i i think in terms of keeping faith
with arapata
i would quite like to keep them because
what we've agreed is that
he will come back to us and then we're
going to work on that reform because the
trees could change shape
you know some of that plant that could
change the seats
will change i guarantee that it's just a
question of how they change so
i'd rather if that's okay rather just
keep it to us i mean you've seen it
um and i said i'll use it as a working
document with the trust but
i'd rather retain possession of that
that's until we've worked with arapada
because i think there will be
and also we'd like to get richard and
his team are working with us
on how we have signage portrayed and
where that goes so
you know just getting that a bit more
refined before we let it out but
particularly those seats on the
front and facing cold stream road you
know
i think tory would be concerned if they
were out in the public at the moment
because it's not
how they'll actually look they're
indicative in this indicative size but
she doesn't want to do any more work on
them until we've got because i know
arapat is quite keen to get
something into that into that concrete
of some shape
so i think we'll be just waiting no
that's fine it's just they have been
asked that uh you know when is it
available yeah yeah no i know there's a
lot of videos
and that was really interesting today
just to actually see it like like that
i'll talk to alistair we could probably
put a couple of car park things because
they're not going to change so there are
some of those shots we could we could
use because the car park is all
it is what it is it's not going to
change so we could do some of that but i
think all of that landscaping around the
actual canopy area we need to just sort
of
keep it working
knowing the car parking charge here
foreign
i